hi I'm Evan Carmichael this is a quick
video that I want to share a little bit
of the process that I use when I create
my videos and some of my workflow I get
asked a lot about productivity and
higher manage my time and I wanted to
share a quick tip while i was doing our
videos on how i do them and how you
might be able to learn and apply some of
this to your business so i'm going to
come close to the camera and show you my
phone so I'm using the Samsung Note 2
and I'm pulling up my email so I have
the gmail app here and I have a lot of
email that comes in I use a lot of
labels and filters so if i click on my
labels here you can see all the
different labels that i have and what i
do every week is i will create as people
write to me step back up there not too
close as people write to me with a
question I'll save it so wednesday
mornings I always do my videos so it's a
wednesday i'm here in my house creating
the video for you guys so that's my
wednesday and as people right in i'll
say i'll make a video reply for you and
from there i'll save it to a special
folder so basically what I do here with
my phone I'll do the mostest on my
computer but with my phone I could see
the labels that I have a lot of
different labels different days
different things that I do on different
days and i'll go down to do videos so i
have a label for do videos and what i do
basically every wednesday these are all
the video questions that i have a lot of
questions that i had still have to get
back to you guys with so I'm sorry for
taking a while but sometimes it happens
so basically these are questions that
people have and I can pull it through
and I can load one up and see what is
all about so this one is asking me to
review a website this one is asking
let's see what else we have here youtube
video youtube questions so I save all
these so this is about Evernote and so
what I'll do here is I'll load this up
every time maybe one side load up my
phone look at all the things that i have
is view videos that i've saved for the
week and then I'll just switch the
labels so after I've done here so this
is my email
I finish the video i just sit down i
changed the label I go I check off do
videos and I go to do videos done and
i'll select that i'm not going to do it
because i haven't actually done this
video and i get back to this person and
then i'll click ok and basically that
will then put in a new folder every time
I finish a video i'll send it off to my
video editor who will add the intro to
it at the music clean up any mistakes
that i have on the video and then i have
to send out an email to them to say hey
I made your video I just go to my do
videos done folder that's been tagged
and labeled here and i'll send it off so
that's how i quickly view my videos and
keep track of its if you look at me on
my phone every now and then i'm just
kind of scrolling through and kind of
find what the next question is but
hopefully I gives you a couple ideas
again anything that I have to do on a on
a regular basis I tried to chunk it up
so the videos i do i used to do it on on
and off but it's i find a lot better to
do it once a week so anything that I try
to do multiple times a week I try to do
it once a week instead and so I find
that as a good way to be able to manage
how we do my videos so hopefully that
helped kind of optic off video for those
of you who are loyal and regular users
if you're trying to figure out ways to
improve your productivity so if you guys
liked the video give it a thumbs up and
might do more of these off the cup one's
for you guys and if you have a question
about productivity or anything else for
them to your business feel free to leave
it in the comment section below I always
read those love seemed to come in so
thank you and I'll see you in the next
episode
you